[Música]
[Aplausos]
ustedes que creen es un pecho igual aquí
que en pekín
sí lo sé lo sé todas las tetas del mundo
son diferentes pero a lo que me refiero
es creen que es más erótico ver un pecho
en una sociedad que en otra aunque bueno
tal vez las tetas no sean el mejor
ejemplo porque entre las teorías
biologicistas que defienden la unión que
tenemos con el pecho por la experiencia
materna la generación de oxitocina que
se da en nuestro cerebro nada más verlas
y que gracias a ellas hemos sobrevivido
cientos y cientos y miles y miles de
años tal vez estemos un poco sesgados
sesgadas 6 gades
pero vamos a ver ustedes nunca han
pensado porque unos labios si estos son
más eróticos que un codo o porque por
ejemplo en algunas culturas llevar una
falda por encima de la rodilla sería
habló absolutamente sexual y sensual y
sin embargo en otras como por ejemplo la
nuestra portamos pantalones cortos tanto
hombres como mujeres sin que eso suponga
ningún escándalo
pues porque el erotismo todo lo que
compone la erótica de los elementos está
impuesto y es aprendido es por eso que
un brick de leche podría ser simplemente
eso un líquido blanco o podría contener
muchos más significados porque el
erotismo es social
ya veo que toman leche ella
[Risas]
para entender un poco mejor esto
deberíamos hablar de género un
constructo social cultural y flexible
que determina lo que tiene que ser hacer
desear y parecer un hombre y una mujer
categorizando los en dos masculino y
femenino así en función de la sociedad
en la que hayas nacido pues esperará de
ti que tengas una determinada identidad
de género y una orientación sexual
también que cumplas con unos roles y
unos estereotipos de género unas
características físicas y psicológicas
así como cosas que te estimulen y te
gusten
porque porque somos seres sociales como
tal nos gusta estar identificados
pertenecer a algo ya alguien eso nos da
tranquilidad tener una etiqueta en la
que podamos cuadrar nos encanta a todos
y es por eso que nacimos en una sociedad
categorizada con costumbres
jerarquizadas y dividida en dos géneros
masculino y femenino pero qué sucedería
si viviéramos sin género
creen que podríamos vivir en un día a
día sin que todos se diferenciará entre
masculino y femenino
ahora voy a hacer una confesión
yo
no así con vulva sí sí nací con vulva y
por eso soy mujer y se me categorizó en
un género femenino como tal se esperaba
de mí que fuera bella que tuviera el
pelo largo y que además tuviera
capacidad comunicativa también se
esperaba de mí que tuviera descendencia
con un marido
y por eso desde pequeña me regalaban
cocinitas y muñecas porque se esperaba
de mí que supiera cocinar y cuidar
por otro lado también se espera de mí
que haya venido peinada de peluquería
maquillada y depilada a un evento como
este hay cosas que no puedo demostrar
pero créanme
[Música]
[Aplausos]
también se esperaba de mí aparte de todo
eso que me sentara con las piernas
cerradas no puedo sentarme con las
piernas abiertas ni tampoco puedo hablar
de todas las parejas sexuales que he
tenido bueno no es que no pueda es que
no debo y todo eso por haber nacido con
vulva
yo he de confesar que todas estas
expectativas a mí me irritan mucho y
entonces es en ese momento donde me
planto y realmente deseo ser un hombre
pero entonces me pongo a pensar y pienso
que no se tendrán esas expectativas pero
se tendrán otras se esperará de mí que
sea fuerte y valiente que sepa cambiar
la rueda de un coche que no exprese
menos mis emociones y además que no me
quede calvo
y entonces ese es el momento donde
realmente sueño con vivir sin género
imagínense eso una sociedad que en lo
que nada esté categorizado / a&a
imagínense la libertad de poder ser
hacer y desear incluso
independientemente del género al que
pertenece al que pertenezco sólo veo
libertad
y no hablo de conceptos extraños de
hecho hay culturas que a día de hoy se
identifican con un tercer género por
ejemplo los cunas en panamá que hablan
de mujer cuna hombre cuna o meguid
miembros celebrados y protegidos de la
sociedad que son niños que habiendo
nacido con pene se identifican con el
género femenino niños que nacen con pene
pero se identifican como mujer y son
miembros celebrados y protegidos de la
sociedad
pero no hablo sólo de ese ejemplo por
ejemplo los amerindios en américa del
norte hablaban de un concepto que era
dos espíritus para identificar a esas
personas que se identificaban con hombre
y mujer cuando llegó la colonización los
colonos no entendían entonces se les
asignaba un género al azar tu hombre tu
mujer
así los interna van ya con los años a
partir de 1990 cuando vuelve a usarse
ese término el término dos espíritus
para identificar a esas personas que se
identifican a la vez con el género
masculino y femenino pero no sólo hablo
de cultura como un tercer género también
a culturas por ejemplo los buggies la
etnia mayoritaria de indonesia que
tienen géneros múltiples yo sería una
mac un raid una mujer femenina oro any
es el hombre masculino charla line es
esa mujer que biológicamente ha nacido
como mujer pero adopte estereotipos de
hombre heterosexual y chola by es el
hombre que biológicamente ha nacido como
hombre pero se identifica con géneros
con estereotipos disculpen de mujer
heterosexual
lejos de defender que esto sea lo
correcto y que desde occidente estemos
equivocados así que me pregunto siempre
por qué nos cuesta tanto tener una
visión más amplia sobre la identidad de
género y así lo charlé una tarde con sam
con sanz tuve una charla muy interesante
a parte de bastante llena de anécdotas
que decir en la que ella me explicaba su
lucha por defender su identidad de
género todo comienza cuando ella tiene
14 años empieza a una búsqueda porque no
entiende si le pasa algo porque todo lo
que le han contado sobre la identidad de
género y la orientación sexual no
concuerda con ella y piensa que estar
equivocado me pasará algo es en ese
momento cuando empieza una búsqueda
hasta que encuentra la etiqueta género
fluido me confiesa que no cree en las
etiquetas piensa que deberían ser
eliminadas pero que en ese momento para
ello fue necesario porque sintió que a
partir de ahí existía medios una frase
que me dejó impactada y decía que lo que
no tiene nombre no existe y que en ese
momento él existía
de repente ya tenía un nombre años han
pasado y aunque me confiesa que ella no
se identifica con esa etiqueta tiene
mucho cariño y ha evolucionado su
identidad de género hasta el día de hoy
sam se define como una persona no de
género no binaria
activista trans vi género a género
masculino
es decir que aprendí mucho de esa charla
aprendí por un lado un montón de
términos que no conocía aprendí que
aunque yo defiendo que tengo la mente
súper abierta la sociedad en la que he
crecido me ha enseñado a no tenerla
tanto aprendí también a escuchar su
historia desde la normalidad más
absoluta porque sam era una persona
contándome su historia exactamente igual
que yo podía contar la mía y también
reflexione porque desde la silla cómoda
donde nos sentamos las personas
heteronormativa mente establecidas todo
esto se ve como algo raro como extraño
como de otro planeta y de hecho a veces
hay personas que se atreven a hacer
preguntas a sanz como por ejemplo mira
perdona tú tienes pene
y cómo te acuestas con alguien y cómo
mantienes relaciones y yo
reflexiona hoy decía si eso es algo
absolutamente incómodo para mí porque yo
no me imagino estar en donde una fiesta
y que alguien me diga mira mal ya todo
ese pecho es tuyo tú lleva wonderbra mi
niña no entiendo algo así es
objetivamente es incómodo además de
surrealista entonces porque hay algunas
personas que si creen que están en el
derecho de preguntarle eso a sam porque
desde esta silla cómoda nos creemos en
el derecho de juzgar valorar y decir que
algo está mal si estamos hablando de una
vivencia y una decisión personal
reflexionamos y reflexiones y entonces
le hice la gran pregunta tú crees que
podemos vivir sin género me respondió y
a partir de ahí he ido haciendo esa
pregunta bueno pues con varias personas
que me he ido no crean que voy por la
calle preguntando eso pero me refiero
pues con grupos que he tenido debates
amigos con los que nos hemos sentado a
mí también me gusta debate vale y es
verdad que al final siempre llego a la
misma conclusión
porque nos cuesta tanto tener una visión
más abierta sobre la identidad de género
quiénes somos si además cada uno de
nosotros y de nosotras hemos tenido que
luchar porque no cuadramos en ese
estereotipo de género que esperan de
nosotros a mí misma amalia cuando vas a
tener hijos oa ti probablemente chico
que me escucha hastío vamos a ver el
partido
no no me gusta el fútbol como no te va a
gustar el fútbol
a día de hoy nos suenan un poco más
términos como transgénero género fluido
género binario o no binario bi género
género inter género intersexual tercer
género si es género semi chico semi
chica y por supuesto hombre y mujer pero
yo espero que llegue un momento en el
que todos y todas todos nos sentemos en
las mismas sillas y esto no sea un
espectáculo que se juzga y se ve desde
fuera yo tú ella nosotres dos o tres
ellas porque al final solo somos tú y yo
[Aplausos]
[Música]